Yeah,
I think it's a bad idea when people try
to design ways to create a public life,
a public square that's free of religion
and the religion talk because there are
people from,
that's how they're comfortable talking.
Some people like Tom to economic theory
or some people have a historical view of
the world.
Some people have a view of the world
that comes from their faith.
People's views come all different
sources.
I think it's important to have a public
square that embraces these different
ways of looking at the world and if
there's something that I believe about
public life that's really it,
that it ought to be open and we ought to
really try to have actual dialogue and
think about dialogue to make it real is
we have to engage in listening with our
ears.
When we tend to do in America is listen
with our mouths.
We tend to listen to the other fellows
argument for the sole purpose of
spotting the errors so we can refute it.
The absurdity that they call
presidential debates in America,
which are not debates at all,
but joint press conference is run by and
for the media.
I think candidates should avoid them
like the plague.
They're horrible,
but that absurdity captures what I mean.
There's no time there for a measured
conversation.
There's no time there to explain a
position.
All you have time do is lash out,
call somebody's name,
use the right buzzwords in it's somebody
else's turn.
Well,
that's not democracy.
That's a mockery.
That is simply a,
an excuse for avoiding what we really
need,
which is actual conversation.
Of course,
our differences instead of buzzwords and
name calling across our differences.
[inaudible].